Uh, and I know her docs, I know where she lives, and I know everything
about her. Uh, and if she ever says anything sideways about me,
I will [__] up her whole life. >> You Why?
>> Why? Cuz that's how I roll. >> Cuz I'm so sorry.
>> Okay, well, you'll be sorry. >> Yeah, okay. >> Pretty
soon, [__]
>> DUDE, WHY DIDN'T ANYBODY EVER TELL ME ETHAN Ralph might
be crazy? This guy's like kind of out of his mind. What the
Guys, Ethan Ralph was arrested last
>> He, um, he's kind of fallen off the wagon, it looks
like, all right? He's been doing
He's getting back on
pills, back on booze. He's getting back at getting back on everything.
Well, actually, I don't know about the booze. I just heard pills,
okay? I just heard that. Mr. Ralph found himself in the company
of a
a known harlot, okay? A known That's how I'll say it. A known
harlot. Uh, he He like started hanging out with a star. Apparently,
on his stream. Now, I think we saw a video somehow of him on
his stream with this woman on the stream, too, right? Didn't
we recently see her on the stream?
One night in Wisconsin. So, he flew to meet her from Mexico.
>> We had to hype up the film, ladies and gentlemen, you
know. >> I assume he's talking about shooting porn with
her. This was Oh, wait. No, this is today. So, this would have
been
yesterday afternoon. This would be right before he got arrested.
They've been waiting for Ralph and Mel part two. I wasn't happy
with the first one. It wasn't exactly my Citizen Kane. I'm thinking
this is going to be Godfather part one, part two, and Citizen
Kane combined, Gone with the
>> and Deep Throat. What do you think? >> Uh, a lot
of, um,
What she said. >> A lot of dramatic intermissions.
>> It's all part of the plan. it's like the Trans-X album
Wisconsin Death Trip. That
What happens in Wisconsin sometimes it stays in Wisconsin.
>> This one's not going to stay in Wisconsin though, actually.
>> No, uh Oh, uh >> Shout out to Hunter Moore, he
sent me the form and everything. So, uh we're doing it by the
book. >> Yeah, I mean I know how the book is. >> Well,
she already knows. I've never read a book. Yeah, you wrote the
book.
>> Yeah, Wisconsin is so >> Shout out Wisconsin.
>> One night in Wisconsin.
>> Hey, this is not our first night here. Last night was
uh That was a bit challenging. There's a haunted hotel. And we
had to get the [__] out of there. And a lot of >> I
Is he just talking about shooting a with this woman? Is that
what the whole thing is about? Also, how stoned is she? What
the [__] is she on? Oh, what the [__]
is happening here? >> Spooky [__] went down
and it was real good though. We're alive, we're here. And uh
we're um
making [clears throat]
>> We're making history. We're making
Stay tuned. Get your popcorn ready. >> I Okay.
Disgusting, disturbing,
all of these things at the same time. Very weird, very gross.
All right. Very weird, very gross.
Okay, I swear somebody linked this video to me, whatever this
video is. I've seen
I've seen this girl on his stream before. I've seen this like
video of this girl and him talking before. But apparently, as
he was going to fly out, people were with the flight. Ethan Ralph
was not allowed to board his flight to attempt to a plact ex-actress
with herpes due to some random hero calling the airport to warn
them. It's
I'm at the airport. I wasn't allowed to board my flight. They
said Stevie Lewis is back Stevie Lewis back called to have me
kept off the flight. They literally named him [laughter] but
this Twitter account just doesn't want you in the
I don't know if that was the at the behest of white guys comedy
or not but it's extremely shady.
I have another one booked now absolutely
Good luck filming your tape this weekend. You're going to need
it. Bro this is
He does have that ace of spades physiognomy. You mean queen of
spades? Is that what you mean webg? What do you mean ace why
did you say ace of spades?
That's not even the bit. >> How you doing this week? >> Somebody
out there in the head and the voice in my head and there's another
person there.
>> You got another person you're talking
>> I don't think so. >> going on here? >> It's
just it's just >> I like
I didn't >> How are you doing? >> I'm talking to
you.
>> I'm caught.
I was I don't know who I was talking to. It was just like I thought
I was talking to you too.
I mean I think I was.
>> Okay. All right. She doesn't have a father does she?
Jesus these people
what happened? So after I guess we had this was on the 11th this
if you remember back to this tweet that I just showed okay. This
was on the 11th these these tweets the video okay. >> We
had to hype up the film ladies and >> in the afternoon
all right.
he says we got to hype up the film. Well nothing hypes the film
more
than early this morning okay last night Ethan Ralph has been
arrested in Milwaukee allegedly disorderly conduct and indecent
exposure. He had left Mexico to meet do drugs and film with ex
star Scarlet Hampton.
She claims she was not aware he wanted and that he smashed her
laptop in rage.
He be doing that. This is the mugshot guys okay. He looks so
rough. I don't know. He kind of just looks like Ethan Ralph to
me. I guess it's rough once you realize he's 40. He looks about
50. He does look like a decade older than he actually is. He
looks pretty old, man.
Now, here's the text. I swear to God
will [__] you up. We can talk or not. You'll regret
this, but good luck. Why, dude? I'm coming now to take that room
and people will go to jail. I don't give a [__] You
stink me so hard it's unreal. I'll be there in 10 minutes. Be
ready. Disgusting Oh, Jesus. You better run.
He said it twice. What the [__] Ethan's crazy.
Video screenshots and discussion on KF. Well, we're not going
to free scroll Ethan's KF page, unfortunately, on the stream.
Probably not something I can do. I'm sure we've got a lot more
coming up though, okay?
Tonight you'll be visited by the three ghosts of the sector.
The sector past, the sector Well, this isn't the present anymore.
We need a We need AI here. This is never been a better case for
AI, okay? To generate us what Ethan Ralph looks like in 2036.
Remember when Digibro punched him? I technically have that. You
have the audio of them fighting? I don't know what I have, to
be honest with you.
Secret recording from Yes, I do. Secret recording of Scarlet.
He hit her in the car, threatened to dox her friends, etc. Hold
on.
7 minutes. >> Dude, I can't have this. I don't want >> You're
threatening my friends.
>> No, I'm >> You threatened my friend You threa-
She you threatened three of my friends
>> I'm telling you if you [__] with me, yeah,
that's how you >> You threatened three of my friends today.
I want to put this on record. >> Just leave. >> One
of my friends won't even talk to me anymore cuz you threatened
her. >> Who cares? I didn't threaten her. >> You
threatened my friend. >> After she blackballed us, yeah,
I did.
Who cares?
Chloe Otts. Uh and I know her dox. I know where she lives. I
know everything about her. Uh and if she ever says anything sideways
about me, I will [__] up her whole life. So then
you
>> Jason Mcgay, I won't cuz I actually like >> No,
you don't. You said No. >> 8 years old. >> You don't
know him. >> Oh, yeah. >> Uh you He's audibly drunk,
by the way. He's like audibly
>> Cuz you suck this
What? No, you said I did, but I didn't. That's not where it goes
like that. >> By the way, as soon as she says that, I know
immediately this person's recording. When they're starting to
like correct things, you say something, they're like correcting
it for the record. That should immediately like raise a red flag
for you, right? You're like correcting something for the record
while I'm talking to you in a private conversation. That's weird.
Not that I've I've never had this happen, but I'm just saying,
as soon as I hear if if I were to hear somebody do that, I'd
just be like, "Oh."
Yeah, I know. No, thank >> No, I'm not. >> I'm going
to pick up the phone and >> 2 minutes and >> Okay,
cool. >> remove her. >> I spent $1,400 on this whole
furniture. And then you know what I get? I get slapped around.
>> You're not wrong.
You didn't get slapped around. >> Dude, that's crazy.
She paid to fly him out? Am I hearing that correctly?
She can fly out
to film a
adult video with.
and she flies out Ethan Ralph.
Really? Really? >> And I get yelled at and blamed for >> You're
you're you're going back to >> I get blamed for everything.
>> You're a dumb [__] and you streamed that
[__] earlier because you're a dumb
And so, >> I'm telling you I'm going [laughter] to pick
up this phone >> You're great. >> and I'm going to
say, "Remove this dumb >> Yeah, I'm going to get another
room in this hotel cuz I have money to do that. Cuz you just
seem to want to pick on my my wallet.
You take away my phone and text people on blast?
And then yell at me? >> It's like the worst conversation.
Disavow Ralph drop it hard hours by the way, but
you pick on my wallet.
like a 50-year-old adult, 40-year-old adult, literally on the
dot 40-year-old adult, by the way. Like not 41 yet.
He just looks old.
>> for my friends.
>> You you You said you were going to You were going to
go and put take care of my friend Chloe. Art. You were going
to get >> Chloe is a Is she Jason agrees with me.
God damn. You're so stupid. >> You are putting people on
blast.
>> Do not throw that at me. >> I'm not. >> Then
calm the [__] down. >> What the [__]
I'm going to throw this at you. That would kill >> Yeah,
well, I mean, I don't You said you were going to kill me today
in the car.
So. Yeah, you did. You said You're like I You know what >> say
that off. I didn't say that. So, okay. So, you just >> You've
been acting like crazy. >> and just go. >> Yeah,
that's what I wanted to do.
Peacefully, but now you're going to put me on blast on your web
streams and you're going to do some demonic things to me, malicious
>> You just insulted me like in the most >> Okay,
so I insulted you cuz you had to wait outside 5 minutes because
I have a friend that I trust that I will not bring a stranger
into my friend's house.
>> You don't even >> not what's going on. No, you're
you're not You don't understand. You don't understand what's
going on here. >> Okay, listen. >> Dude, Jesus Christ,
come on. Like stop.
>> Okay, I won't touch you. I don't care. >> Okay,
then calm down, okay?
>> It's like really bothering me.
Okay, cuz
And I watched it. I apologize and I said I'm sorry.
Well, I didn't know you were having side conversations about
my everything that happened between us with all these people
when I keep my personal life out of the the I don't
And then you yell at me if I won't post a picture
for you.
If I don't post a picture, you I mean you get yelled at.
But I am done with public relationships.
Respect my privacy.
Respect my friends.
>> I'm done with public relationships.
You're dating the leakiest streamer that exists on the internet.
The guy who like doxes people, the guy What are you talking about?
I'm I'm done with public relationships.
This is the most public relationship guy. >> Respect my
family. >> I'm telling you for the >> I have respect
for those things. >> And and I'm not mad at you either.
>> No. No, but you've been threatening my family and my
friends. >> You've been threatening me. You said I I [__]
with you, if I [__] with you, you are going to you
are going to destroy me and burn me to the ground.
>> Wow. You do not go after my family, my friends, my You
do not go at me like that. Why? Cuz >> everything in your
life. And so,
>> Why? Cuz that's how I roll.
I want to have >> It's it's not >> actual real and
not
I am a dumb [__] for a year because I don't want
to [__] and get hurt again. >> It's not personal.
It's it it's business. And >> Oh, yeah. Okay, that's not
what you told >> You embarrassed me >> This is not
business. Me spending all this [__] money is not
business.
Okay, I'm sorry I embarrassed you. Okay, I'm sorry. >> embarrass
me. >> I embarrassed you. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. No, I am
sorry. I'm so sorry. >> can tell. >> I'm so sorry.
>> Okay, well, you'll be sorry. >> Yeah, okay. >> Pretty
soon, mother [__]
>> This guy's crazy. Why didn't anybody ever tell me Ethan
Ralph might be crazy? This guy's like kind of out of his mind.
What the >> Yeah, you'll be Yeah, you will be.
>> We'll be sorry, okay. >> Okay, think I won't.
>> I know the
>> I know his exact address. I know >> Oh, you are
not sending no one to nobody's home. You better not. >> I
will.
You don't know me.
So, [__] me and keep [__] me and you'll
find out.
>> Oh, sorry. Yeah, that's a joke. Yeah, Ethan Ralph's
[__] up. Everybody knows
>> Yeah, that's what'll happen. >> I ain't don't
want >> You better step down. >> Hey, you're okay.
>> You better step down. >> You better step down.
>> Okay, cool. Wonderful. >> And if you think I won't,
you're wrong. I will. And so
And I'll tell it all. I'll I'll give a total retelling on my
show. >> Hurting other people?
>> Is I like hurting people. Yeah. >> You like to
hurt people, cool. >> Well, I like to hurt people who hurt
me and they're hurting me right now. And so >> That's okay.
>> I was working things out with you for the last four
or five hours talking. >> Okay, well, it's over. Just get
the [__] out of my [__] >> Yeah,
yeah, okay, cool. Um >> You You think I'll go >> They
put you on the Dahmer level for a reason. Yeah, yeah, it's my
They put you on the Dahmer floor for a reason. You know why?
Cuz Dahmer killed somebody on this floor. Ambassador Hotel, Milwaukee,
Wis
why is Why is she giving away her location, too? >> They
put you on the fifth floor for a reason. You know that? >> You're
lucky. Go. >> It's cruel. You're cruel person. >> Just
go.
Ralph the Mail is a force of nature. He kind of is.
He looks rough, okay? He does look rough, but
but shockingly,
he'll outlive everybody, okay? Nobody who's ever snarked on Ethan
Ralph will outlive him. That's a That's a fundamental rule of
the universe, okay? If you've ever laughed at Ethan Ralph, if
you've ever made fun of him, you will die before him, okay? You
will die before him. That's just I didn't make the rules, okay?
God made that rule. That's not me. This him post looks maxing,
okay? All right. Okay, we've got a little bit more. We've got
actually a lot of stuff more. Jesus.
Uh Ralph reacted to that video. Give me a second. He had a He
had a comment on Some [__] lmao.
Wait. No, no, no, no, no. This is different audio then. Hold
on. Hold on. What am I not getting right here?
Oh, no. No, no. This was Wait.
I thought this was the fight when he got arrested. This is the
day before. Why would they hang out again after this
What the This is the day before.
This is 7 7:11 a.m. on March 11th.
Last night
Last night is when he got arrested, dude. What?
So, he was mad about that. Physical tussle in the car while she
is driving. Jesus Christ.
>> You want to go live now? >> No, not really, but
>> I just drove past another sign that had shown it respect.
>> Please get to a gas station. >> So, [__]
you. Did you say [__] you? Yeah, I know. [__]
you more. I'm tired of this
>> I am tired of this
there is no there is no >> Don't ever say that to me again,
man. No, I will say whatever I want. >> Was it because
she said you he's >> There is no
There is no Don't ever say that to me again, man. No, I will
say whatever I want. Okay, just drive me a dog. >> You
can hear the car steadily picking up speed, yeah. >> So,
you can go do whatever the [__] you want, dude.
>> I will do whatever the [__] they want to
do in my life. >> That's right. So will I.
so will you. Well, first of all, I'm running out of gas. I'm
going to run out of gas. >> No [__] that's
why I told you to go to the gas station, genius. >> Yeah,
yeah. Oh, yeah, I got >> There's gas stations right there,
god. >> Oh, no, well, that's not the one. That's Wendy's.
>> Okay, they have gas stations there, too. Do you not
see the next >> I don't know what's more likely at this
point, that she slurs like this while she's sober or that she's
just up and driving. Like, which one is more likely?
It's hard to say. >> Yeah, yeah. Oh, yeah, I >> There's
gas stations right there, god. >> well, that's not the
one. That's Wendy's. >> Okay, they have gas stations there,
too. Do you not see the next
>> Stop this stream, Megan. Oh my god, stop it. Stop it.
Stop it. I can't drive and I can't do that [__] I
can't do this [__] right now. I'm a good >> THEN
WHY THE [__] DID YOU START THE >> JESUS. OKAY.
All right.
Okay, no one called the cops. Everything is totally fine.
Hey, @RalphRetort
and I are okay. We are totally fine, dude. Constant constant
like wellness check updates for everybody else.
>> It's like that morning again. Oh, no, this would be
a different morning, but yeah, this Sorry, this is the 11th.
The previous one was the 10th. This would be after maybe the
other fight that she
My god, man. What a mess. What a mess. Might be after
We're all fine would be what what what gets posted, Jesus. He
shared some of the messages that were exchanged between
Hold on.
Why is that sensitive? Okay. Okay. Okay. Wait. Wait. Hold on.
Here we go. Here we go. Here we go. Here we go.
Uh This is last night. Ethan Ralph just destroyed my MacBook
Pro, threw it across the room, and ran away. Lost my grandma's
voicemails, my music compositions, poetry writings, and my intellectual
property. As homemade porn videos 100%. Then he ran off with
some document he may be signed so he could be proved. No, sir,
you are not. Revenge raging and doxing my family and friends
not my book. Neither is extortion. Not in my book. I Dude, she
she types like she speaks, and that's not good. Okay?
She literally
Revenge raging and doxing my family and friends not in my book.
Neither is extortion.
Fantastic.
Awesome.
Ralph, run. Choose one.
Bro, these people hate Ethan.
And then we have the DMs here, which is the ones we read already.
Okay. All right. All right.
You were warned, Scarlet. So is he. Oh,
And then there's uh
There's Kino Shay in the comments, okay?
You're serious. You can call the sheriff to get domestic violence
and charges added.
People trying to get Ralph with men.
He was angry posting 18 hours ago about
Dumping will always be dump sad but true.
Do the rest of the stream in the Mama Jill F. accent. You mean
the Hila Klein accent? Do you mean the Hila Klein accent? I'm
a big fan of Nicholas
Is that what you meant? But you always do your research.
I'm sorry. Can I I need the Anisa clip. Hold on. >> I'm
a big fan of Nicholas DeOrio. What can I say?
>> I'm a big fan of Nicholas DeOrio. What can I say?
Dude, like actually Ronald Well, no. Kind of just Arnold Schwarzenegger,
like female Arnold Schwarzenegger. Yeah.
Bro, I'm actually going to let this play now because apparently
somebody's going to compare the two, and I do want to see the
comparison. Everybody's like, "Oh, that" Dude, the cope they
do. Ela Hellsing sounds that That sounds nothing like Ela. That's
like Yoda or something. It's nothing like Ela at all. If they've
got comparison audio in here, I need >> good research.
>> You literally didn't sound anything like her. You just
did a silly voice. >> Oh, no. Oh, no. >> I feel like
your coverage has been really good on topics that I end up watching,
like you're really
You're good with research. That in the end, what? Only like two
people will be approved to work for and talk to and like hang
out with what? I don't understand. I got a sweet. I hear a loud
>> silly one >> Oh, they're not at the desk. >> No,
you shut the [__] up. He doesn't know [__]
about it. >> No, he doesn't. >> He does not. But,
he talks like with such authority. Oh my god. She's friends with
Denholm's. >> How hard did Ethan nod to the clip of Anisa
doing Ela's voice? Bro. >> Denholm's is streaming this
story about our kid drama.
I don't do drama. >> How much do you actually care? >> Because
there's a watermelon on >> We made this like over a year
ago.
>> Sorry, she's taking on preaching. Baby, say for your
friend.
>> The problem is that she doesn't. >> That's the
problem. >> That's the problem.
Who else do we want to burn today?
I just hate that he's acting like he still has something up his
sleeve, but he won't do it. He's too classy. He's not going to
go nuclear. Oh, wow. Thank you, iDubbz. Like we gave a >> I'm
a big fan of Nicholas DeOrio. What can I say? You do your research.
>> It's so
I'm sorry. I again I'll just say I know nothing else about Anisa.
I don't Well, I know a little bit about how like people hate
them and she's apparently really cringe. But that clip that clip
is so perfect.
It's so good, okay? It's so [__] good. Ralph was
released 5 hours ago. I did see free bird. Free bird was the
tweet when he got out. Free
Free bird.
Bro, unstoppable, man.
I literally was looking at my bracelet all night thinking this
is the worst mugshot I've ever taken and it's definitely trending
on Twitter right
He's not wrong. He's not wrong. That [__] was trending
on Twitter instantly.
She picked him up. They posted a video to say, "Yeah, I'm I'm
getting that. I'm getting that impression that that's how this
is going to go down, okay? She has nothing to do with me being
arrested.
>> I'm out. I'm free. You see who I have here with me,
Miss Scarlett Hampton.
Contrary to popular belief, she had nothing to do with anything
that happened with me getting arrested.
We did have a little disagreement.
And I was given a courtesy ride to the airport by Milwaukee's
finest. I got to the airport,
continued to imbibe, continued to drink. I got into a got into
an argument with somebody at the airport.
There was no indecent exposure.
It was public intoxication
and disorderly conduct. Everything's fine with Scarlett and I.
I know some things are said on Twitter, don't care. I'm
>> Somebody at the airport bar? Cuz that's clearly where
they are, right? With the big windows in the back? Somebody's
just sitting at the airport bar trying to get a meal in before
their flight. They're going to listen to Ethan Ralph rant about
No, I'm not beating this girl. I'm not beating this girl at all.
>> I'm free as a bird.
I'm supposed to come back I think in May.
Free as a bird.
I think I'm supposed to come back in May for the charges are
so minor
public intox and disorderly. I can probably get a lawyer to to
show up where I don't even have to show up. But we'll see maybe
I'll have another excuse to to visit Wisconsin
besides the lovely Miss Hampton. Did you want to say anything
here?
>> We're about to have nice burgers. >> Oh yeah,
that's right. I forgot we're at Culver's. Shout out to Ice Dancer.
I heard you sending a lot of messages last night, sweetie. Well,
you I didn't need a bail actually.
I didn't need to post bail. I only had to wait 12 hours to sober
up. So I I heard you were encouraging her not to post my bail
but no bail needed.
I'm free as a bird.
I'm loving it. I didn't bail you. >> I think we all have
to grapple with and accept the fact that Ethan Ralph has infinite
plot armor, okay? He will never do be defeated by the law. The
law can never tame Ethan Ralph, all right? Infinite plot armor,
he will never be [__] with by the law. It cannot
contain him.
>> He probably would have bailed me out but I didn't need
that. So
>> I feel like we've got more stuff. Didn't one of these
guys hopped on a stream today, did they not? They were both?
Okay. Do we have those?
They're hanging out together. Ooh, there's a merch segment here.
Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Medukar apparently posted the charges
for Ralph.
Charges were
He got out without bail though.
I was I was like worried about this doxing Ralph and then I realized
that there's probably no reason to be concerned about that that
whatever you are capable of doxing on Ralph it has been doxed
out. Hold on.
I told you guys that Medukar was a Zionist shill for at least
3 years now. Put another dollar in the Ralph was right jar or
maybe a coin.
Okay. Don't [__] with Israel fat boy. Enjoy prison.
Mazel tov.
the the decline of Medukar has been very sad for everybody, I
feel like. I feel like nobody's super happy about the decline
of Metokur.
All right, we got a merch segment reacting to all this. >> Now,
I got this news
basically moments ago. This came from AF Stream Watch on X, who
tweeted this out. Ethan Ralph has been arrested with a question
mark? So, of course, I had to go look and I wanted to go verify.
I I could believe it. I could believe
Right? I don't know. Is he balding? His hairline was always super
high, wasn't
This is This is some loss here. That's rough. Little rough. >> by.
And here it is. This is the Milwaukee County Sheriff's Department
website and uh looks like as of 3:12, which is today, sometime
in the past 4
Ethan Ralph has been booked
into the Milwaukee County Jail. Uh we don't have any charges.
I don't think so. Okay, we don't have any charges yet. However,
we do have a little bit of uh God, everything's been nuts. I'm
so sorry, guys. Earlier today, uh Ralph and Scarlet
uh posted a video.
And uh in that video, they both looked uh little burnt out, little
worse for wear, and um both of them declaring on Twitter and
in the video that uh the entire fight that we watched, that you
saw first on Nightwave Radio,
was a work. I We were all credibly informed to >> This
is what these guys call a bit, right? When they say it's a work,
it's just a bit. >> today by Ralph and Scarlet, they were
working us. Because we all know just what an amazing actress
Scarlet Hampton is, right?
Um so they made a video, but they were tweeting out like, "Haha,
we worked you guys. It was all in good fun. And then
he [snorts] started like tweeting some crazy [__]
about her tonight. Um Scarlet
posted this. This is
>> Did we just get a Dicker's raid? Somebody said Dicker's
raid? Did we just get a Dicker's raid? Thank you, Dickers. We
just watched you threaten Konstantin Kisin live. That was [__]
up, but thank you very much for the raid. I appreciate it. Gucci
Jesus, thank you for the 10 months as well. >> This is
what I think the charges will be related to. This was 10:30 p.m.
tonight. Ethan Ralph just destroyed my MacBook Pro, threw it
across the room, and ran away.
Lost my grandma's voicemails, my music compositions, poetry writings,
and my intellectual property. He then he ran off with some document
he made me sign so he can be approved. No, sir, you are not revenge
raging and doxxing my family and friends, not in my book. Neither
is
Oh, boy.
Uh now I tweeted out uh as soon as I saw that uh >> I'm
going to probably skip to the Pot Awful. There's a Pot Awful
call from earlier today, okay? >> Oh man, I forgot. I don't
even know why I was arguing with you last night. I
You watched some of the Pot Awful stuff
I wonder if they actually have the full video up. No, there isn't.
>> All we got is is this guy. >> Yeah, I kind of
had a feeling. >> I don't even remember what You were making
the joke about the Ralph about or whatever the hell, and I was
like, "Damn, I was saying that to Jesse?" And he just ran
>> I just like saying Ralph about. It's a funny word. >> you
so much. I hear you laughing. Yeah.
>> All right. Yeah, I can hear >> He is dating a
woman who eat who ate Ethan's out. Wait.
Mersh is or
Wait, Mersh is or
the Pot Awful guy is. Which one?
Please don't say the pot awful guy. >> Guess who I'm with.
>> It sounds like a familiar voice.
>> What is >> Yeah, I There's been a lot of a lot
of lies told. We're about to cut a video. Actually, um >> Yeah,
a lot of lies told right now. >> We'll do that. Let's do
that before we leave here.
I She had me arrested. >> What is the deal with uh Mersh
and you got your you did public indecency or something like that?
>> I don't know. He just made that up. I got disorderly
conduct and public intox. >> You shut it. I'm on a move.
>> And they have a They make you stay mandatory like 12
hours. It's the sober up, right? Um and so, as soon as the 12
hours hit, they let me go. Like it was like 12:15 or some [__]
So, >> I know I did something happen. He said they'd give
me a ride to the hospital. >> Well, we did get into a disagreement
here at the hotel.
>> Yeah, it was a good time. We did have a little disagreement,
uh
>> But yeah, I mean >> So, what happened? I'll tell
you, but I'm going to put the video out in a sec.
>> You know me. I got mad and stormed and started walking
down the street. Uh and >> You can't tell where we are.
>> I grabbed my Well, I left half of my clothes in her
car, which I forgot about. But
And the police I don't even remember this, by the way. The police
picked me up and gave me a courtesy ride to the >> Yeah,
cuz I told them you had a flight and you had the cats and you
had the >> And then I got to the airport
and apparently I was allegedly belligerent uh there at the airport.
Uh so,
>> crazy I was drinking. >> And I had a big bottle
of vodka, too. Probably shouldn't have been swigging out of that,
but >> So, just to be clear, this was something that happened
at the airport. This is >> Yeah, this is something totally
separate from So, I mean, you know, we got into an argument uh
and that led to me going to the airport, but it didn't have anything
to do with her.
And I said I'm not pressing charges. I'm not Don't want to. I
just want He needs got a flight in the morning. He's got cats
at home. >> Yeah, unfortunately, I'm going to have to eat
that charge, I think. But, uh
These mother want me to come back to Milwaukee on some bogus
ass little
petty ass charges on it's like May or some [__] I
bet I can hire a lawyer to [__] where I don't even
have to show up, but
>> Dude, this is like him work shopping the video that
he posts later in the day. He's like photoshopping it on a live
stream. Sorry, photoshopping, work shopping it on a live stream,
not photoshopping it. He's literally work shopping it like
I bet you I I wonder if I could get a lawyer to like go and do
that and then he he heard He's over here. He's like, "I'm just
going to get a lawyer to take care of it for me."
>> It's not a serious
>> He's not going to get a lawyer to take care of it for
him. He's literally just going to ignore it, right? We all know
that. He's going to go back to Mexico and he's going to pretend
that that charge didn't happen. >> You know what the CEO
said and told me said, you know, um they'll probably put out
a warrant on you if you don't show up, but you're in Mexico and
uh you know, I I don't think that uh you know, they would even
issue a nationwide warrant. They actually told me he said I can
just skip out if I wanted. I'm like, "What is this?" This guy's
pretty based. Uh but, I ain't going to do that cuz it's too much
of >> That's definitely like a Kino Casino viewer who knows
who Ralph is. Like, you could totally get away. Just just leave,
man. Don't even deal with it. Don't even deal with it, Ralph.
Just head back to
So, you can watch you get arrested when you come back to America
again, okay? Thank you. He's still going. She's She's kind of
yapping in the background. I wonder if she's on the phone too.
>> I don't want that out there. And who knows if they're
like those ones in uh Minnesota, they might put out a nationwide
warrant. So, >> Right. Best not to chance it. >> Yeah.
Yeah, I need to get off of that type OF [laughter] MINDSET. THAT'S
WHY I WAS LIKE, "BRO, why are you even telling me this? You work
for the god damn state, man."
>> Seriously, like yeah, you can just break the law. Yeah,
let's go there.
>> We're going to get Nathan >> You really don't
have going back up. Since you live in Mexico
No one had TO PAY BAIL.
>> IS THE PERSON THE ICE person is that Merce's girlfriend
who's messaging her, the Scarlet person?
>> Oh, me too.
>> Plus these are not like man, this kind of you know,
first off in my life are not exactly abnormal for one, but at
the
people get drunk. Hold on.
People get trashed at the airport.
the pilots do, so.
>> Yeah, EXACTLY. THEY'RE They're on They got more dope
in them than Walgreens. Yeah, um
>> Give me a shot of the vodka.
>> An hour ago. Sorry, I I'm not >> No, cuz you didn't
hit me, you know. >> I know that. That's for me to remember,
>> You know, the laptop was only thing uh But that's all
>> I should have hit Ice at that fact. Yeah, but >> Uh
actually you didn't hit me. >> I know. >> So they
made a whole thing like you assaulted me in my car. You also
didn't hit me in my car. You never hit me. So the the whole story
is wrong right now. Like um and I didn't press charges. Like
the police like they didn't give me a case number. I told them
that I just wanted you to get to the airport. You have cats feeding
in the morning. You have a flight in the morning. They said we're
giving you a courtesy ride to the airport. And then I then I
see >> I got myself arrested long first time. I got myself
arrested, which has happened more times than I can count. >> Sorry
you're not >> Yeah, you you and airports barely mix. >> Dude,
dude, my god, it's like TNT.
Every time I go almost something
It was the copious amount of alcohol. Now that I think about
it. >> Uh but uh is that? >> Got a little freak out
your speaker when we got pulled over. >> Where? Oh, do
you still have those >> Why? They took your speaker. >> I
don't know what you're talking about. It might You getting arrested
constantly might have to do with the constant substance abuse.
Who would have thought?
All right. I think we are five subs away from another hour on
the stream, guys. If we do more content after this, if we go
past Ralph, we'll probably go to the Candace stuff, I
I think it'll be the Candace stuff. >> All right. Well,
maybe I still have it. I don't know what I have. >> Wait.
Wait. When we pass >> I thought they gave me a >> I
think we're going to get get stopped right here again. I think
we're going to pass it and get another bottle. >> No, I
don't know about that. Uh unless you really want >> what's
going to happen this >> All right. Okay. >> I might
need some milk. >> You can see what a great influence she
is. All right. Uh >> We got a freak out.
>> All right. Fine. Let's stop there then.
>> Do you know where it is? >> Very lucky place.
Yeah, they're in front of my green number. >> Okay. Well,
I mean, uh kind of >> We're going to go to court. >> Long
night.
>> You know, we actually >> we might have >> Anyway,
so I'm sorry about arguing. I don't even know what was going
on with her. All right. >> I was at the airport I think
by the time that happened. Um so
>> I don't take these things seriously. >> Yeah,
I know. Come on. Like, what the I don't even know where the [__]
that was. Uh that's like one moment in time >> Yeah, all
they told me the cops said that you were very intoxicated.
>> And I told them um They said, "We're just going to give
him a courtesy ride." I said I >> Here, I'll be honest.
I I don't mind like the Pot Off a Guy seems pretty funny. I like
your setup. His podcast setup, if you guys have ever seen it,
is pretty cool, in my opinion.
Hold on. Who's that guy? >> Mersh just made that [__]
up. >> I'm sure I'm sure he's going to come out with the
um mobile. All right. I Now, this looks like maybe it's a little
better. They're actually sitting down.
We've got this guy, Kevin Brennan,
Had him on his stream. I don't even know what MLC stands for.
MLC podcast. Hold on. What is MLC?
MLC is This guy looks like Misery Loves Company. The Misery Loves
Company podcast, apparently. >> I told your friend >> out
of Milwaukee.
>> Yeah, well, that was the plan, you know. I got I got
detained
here in Milwaukee.
I got a very nice breakfast courtesy of the county jail. >> Courtesy
of more taxpayer dollars in Wisconsin, right?
>> We love Wisconsin here. >> Yes, it was not >> What
the
This guy had no emotion in his face when he spun that around.
What Hold on, watch that again. >> Courtesy of more taxpayer
dollars in Wisconsin, right?
>> We love Wisconsin here.
>> Just literally no no emotion there
He just spun that around, didn't smile at all. >> It was
not >> We love Wisconsin. >> I love Yes, my favorite
state ever
>> Milwaukee, I love so much. I'm sure we'll get this thing
cleared up. You know, I did not it was not indecent exposure.
That was a lie by Mersh. I don't know I don't know why he's obsessed
about my
reproductive organ, but he seems to be. Anyway, um it was I was
drunk at the airport and they gave me disorderly conduct and
We'd had an argument but with me it was just me being drunk at
the airport.
>> Dude, I don't know. What is it What is it about having
a stream?
>> Hey Kevin, there's a mistake. Like people online are
saying that he hit me and did a >> I I don't understand
somehow
I still don't understand a lot of >> He did not do any
of these things. Uh >> He thought >> What happened
was uh He got >> he really drunk though. >> You got
very drunk and you kind of started cracking.
>> Did he break Did he break your laptop? >> He ran
away and then I got to let go of I want to make sure that you
know >> No, I grabbed my >> the videotape. >> I
grabbed >> the videotape. >> I grabbed my and I walking
down the road, actually, and >> Yeah, he's talking
>> Ethan Ralph is winning her.
How did he [__] this up?
Wait, no, this is not before. This is now. This is after he went
to jail. This is after everything. They're hanging out >> I
don't remember this season. She had the car. a courtesy ride
I don't know how I got to the airport.
I know how I got to the jail. Because once they started arresting
me, I kind of summed it up a little bit.
>> Yeah, but why
Did you just say
Did you say he knew they arrested him when he went to jail? >> I
summed it up a little bit.
>> Oh, he knew what he was doing when he went to jail.
Yeah, but why Why did the cops Why did the cops show up in the
first place? >> Cuz when you're drunk and talking sh
>> show up They showed up at a hotel? >> Uh no, no,
no. >> No, this is not at the airport where I got arrested.
>> No, no, no. >> No, they they they they
>> This guy strikes me as like too old to be streaming.
He's like yelling like my grandpa would into THE MICROPHONE.
WHY DID THEY NO, WHAT?
WHY DID THEY ARREST YOU, ETHAN?
Why E
Ethan, why did they arrest you?
>> They drove They drove you to the airport, but where
Where did they the
Yeah, but why did the cops show up in the first place? >> We
we had a a disagreement. >> So, what happened is um there
were two things that happened, which I'm not going to mention.
>> Hey, Scarlet, can you take your glasses off cuz it's
going to
>> Dude, I thought he was going to say, "Hey, Scarlet,
could you shut the [__] up so I can hear what Ethan's
saying?"
Cuz it she is She's kind of just droning a lot. Like I'm not
trying to be misogynistic. She's kind of just yapping
saying nothing all the [__] time. >> So, you
have a black eye. >> Oh, good point.
>> Maybe [clears throat] I should TAKE MINE
PUT THE glasses on.
>> No, I he I want to correct a lot of this news that's
been going around because uh these keyword farms and all the
mail well they log fake news. They want to see that like I was
hit or slapped in my car. Also first of all Ralph >> Yeah,
but we saw we saw some of the videos. They did get a little they
They got a little testy. >> go and usually verbal things
can be calmed down much much much easier than anything that's
would ever be physical.
Um and I didn't send the cops on Ralph. Um he did that to him.
>> I was drunk at the airport like we had a >> Wait,
wait, you called Well, who called the cops? Who called the cops?
>> Well, I don't know. I'm not sure exactly who it was,
but >> So that I mean we were >> Scarlett, were you
ever were you ever concerned were you ever thought he >> Dude,
what What the [__] is this inter- This interview
is just weird as [__] This interview is just bizarre.
You're in underground No, Lucas, I literally Ryley's never once
complained about this. Ryley doesn't complain about this. Ryley
would probably like to to argue with those people more
to be honest with you. I feel weird about it personally.
Like it it annoys me. I don't know if I don't think it actually
upsets him. I think he just sees people he can like yell at and
argue with.
Responding to Lucas on >> Were you ever concerned like
you were with Matt Meade or no? >> Much worse. Wait, wait,
no. So can I Can I say this? So me and Ethan I didn't want him
to leave the hotel. And I wasn't forcing him to stay there, but
the reason why I didn't want him to leave is he just had a lot
to drink and I didn't want him going outside. He wasn't about
to drive and he wasn't tasing his dad. Like he wasn't beating
up his dad so that he could drive a car and then get chased by
police and go to jail. No, Ethan was walking out on the street
and I didn't want him to leave. >> Why was he going to
the street to get something to eat?
>> He's an American.
He's an American that I flew in. I flew in from Mexico.
So, I flew an American from Mexico
on my dollar to just be like >> She talks like a 4-year-old
who doesn't have a concept of conversation and asking questions.
You know how like toddlers just yap about nothing? They say sentences
that sort of work, but they're like desperate facts that don't
connect into a story.
That's what she's like.
All the time.
>> He's an American.
He's an American that I flew in. I flew >> He's an American.
He's an American that I flew in from Mexico.
It's an American I flew in from Mexico. >> So, I flew an
American from Mexico.
>> So, she flew in an American from Mexico. >> Um
on my dollar to just be like
>> On her dollar to just be like Ethan, >> They took
ME OUT. THEY TOOK ME OUT TO GET SOMETHING TO EAT. That's exactly
right. I was >> Are you allowed Are you legally
My sources are saying different things. Are you allowed in this
country, Ethan >> Yes, you see me here in Milwaukee. What
the [__] >> I don't know. You could be a Mexic-
It's the legal That's the legal mindset
How could I be in America if I was not allowed to be How could
I be in America if I had a warrant on me? How could I be in America
if it was illegal for me to be here? >> It's a go with
this point. >> No, I sent me and I will BE >> SORRY.
I'M TEAM ETHAN and no, I guess Steel Toe,
>> Yeah, man. >> Steel Toe, my guy? Yeah. >> I
guess he's He loves He loves you, Kevin. Steel Toe does. >> How
do you know that? >> Well, you said Remember he said He
said the best MLC episode was the episode he was on there and
where he debated a few other people with you. And I guess >> He
did say he Well, he's kind of big up on himself right like >> that's
what Chad wants to uh marry me. >> Yeah, Chad uh Chad thinks
he could say he could set you straight cuz you need a you need
a good man. You need you need a guy who's allowed in the country.
>> machine and then it says card declined because he likes
the credit cards and I like the cash. >> But either Ralph
either Ralph you
>> Dude, this is
just like dystopian to watch. I have no idea what I'm watching
here.
>> I mean you have a history
uh with
this reminds me of the black You know the black mirror episode
with the guy who's like selling humiliating acts
to make money so that he could pay for like his family or whatever.
That's what this reminds me of.
On both sides actually but to different extents on both sides.
And to some extent that's like what I do too but my god. >> With
uh domestic situations uh wives and children and I don't know
all of it. >> I mean you have kids >> Like what what
what's your personal life like? I mean I I don't know. You're
right. I've had a
>> You're watching the average rural American discovering
the internet.
I That's true. I literally ranted about this earlier tonight
so I can't I literally can't say no to this.
It's rough, man. >> No, no, that's fair. My personal life
is way better than yours. Let's put it that way. So I don't have
any charges. I can go to any state in this country. And I >> Hey,
I'm your boy. >> I've never been arrested for having for
indecent exposure. >> I haven't either. >> No, we're
so >> One time the cop One time the cop tried >> I
was arrested for public indecency. >> One time the cops
arrested me for decent exposure cuz I I got a decent size >> You
were probably getting arrested for DUI or
>> Dude, he he had to take four swings at that to get a
chance to say it.
Dude, four swings at that one. I
>> The drone >> I mean I should have been I should
have been arrested all right for indecent exposure and >> because
they No, no, no, no, no, no, no, NO, NO, NO, NO, NO, NO, NO,
NO, NO, NO, NO, NO, NO, NO, NO, NO, NO, NO, NO, NO, NO, NO, NO,
NO, NO, NO, NO, NO, NO, NO, NO, NO, NO, NO. >> THEY'RE
GOING TO fight because they both want to be the center of the
story.
That's why she's doing this. She wants to be famous, right?
And they both want to be the center of the of attention for everybody
and they're going to fight over actually
I feel I feel like they're going to fight in this I feel like
they're going to fight in this episode right now. >> Okay.
Okay, so
That didn't happen though. Okay, so the cops the cops came to
wherever you were, they took you they arrested you and then they
took you to the airport and then why are you not at the airport?
Why are you not on a
It's all [__] up. Why Let Let Ethan Ralph answer.
Let Ethan Ralph answer. >> I was there with the police
officers >> No, you weren't. You're not Ethan Ralph. You
weren't arrested. Were you detained? Were you in the jail cell?
Did you get your mugshot taken? Shut up. Were you Was your mugshot
taken? Ethan Ralph, why are you not on a flight >> He is
was in jail. >> Why are you not on a flight to Mexico right
now?
>> They just haven't booked it yet. You want to buy me
one?
>> Uh yeah, try Travelocity. I usually use that. But I
Seriously. >> Why do you give a [__] Like I
mean, yeah, I'm going back to Mexico. >> No, cuz I saw
a lot of tweets today you
>> and public intox you dumb ass. >> But why did
they take you to the
>> Because they it wasn't a big situation. >> But
they want you to leave. So why Why don't you to
>> So the weird thing is is it sounds like he got picked
up by the cops from their hotel and then they took him to the
Like it's a domestic violence situation. He says, "I got a flight
tomorrow. Just take me to the airport. You don't have to take
me cuz they'll split the two people up, right?" I think that
kind of implies there was a domestic violence situation that
they didn't resolve they didn't really resolve or anything. Didn't
result in charges.
But they were going to split them up. They probably sent him
to the airport,
And then
Yeah, from sending him to the airport, then that more people
to come to the airport pick him up cuz he gets drunk at the airport.
>> So wait, why didn't you leave? >> I got once in
the airport and got more drunk and got into arguments. >> Bro,
that's got to be so expensive to get drunk at the airport. That's
[__]
Everything at the airport is so expensive. It's got to cost a
ton of money to get drunk at the airport, right? Especially for
Ethan, he's a big >> people at the airport >> And
then why Okay, okay, why are you getting into so many arguments
with
>> Well, you know, you drink too much [__]
happens, man. >> So, do you have a drinking problem or
you just on like spring break? >> Well, I mean
I I think I think everybody enjoys uh certain things and >> Yeah,
sure, I do too. So, are you combining uh meds with alcohol?
>> Um never intentionally, of course. I I don't know. >> What
does that even mean? Why do you act like you're 10? Why you don't
know Why you don't >> It happened. Uh you know, I'm sure
it was I'm sure it was a mistake. Uh but
>> That's a yes. >> Are you on Are you take Xanax
or something every day? >> Uh I do have a prescription
for Xanax, >> Okay, so but then you drink every day on
top of that. >> Yeah, I don't drink every day, no. >> Okay,
just when you're with Skyler.
>> Well, she drinks a good bit herself. I don't know if
you >> She likes She's a fun gal. I have I I've never been
with Skyler, but >> Kevin, she goes pretty hard, bro. Like
I mean, I'm just telling you
>> How is she in a sack? I'm asking for >> I don't
think that's appropriate to talk about on >> Okay, I'm
kidding, of course. I don't expect you to
>> It's like Dude, what? Why would you ask that? By the
way, you get a get a reasonable idea that from just Googling
her name, okay?
You just Google her name, you get a reasonable idea. >> Marsh.
Hey, [__] Marsh. I'm not watching porn, star. I have
people that want to book me for scenes. By the way, he lied about
the indecent exposure. I wish that I had gotten hit with that
cuz I think >> You make us look bad. >> That's like
a cool charge. And no, it's just being drunk and dumb in public.
That's literally >> I was relieved. >> public intox
and disorderly conduct both mean. So, yeah, I wish it was something
cool like pulling my guy, but no. >> No, that's not cool.
>> I'm just saying. >> No, I'm saying what I'm saying,
too, is that I was relieved when I found saw his
>> I wasn't That wasn't That wasn't pretty >> was
worried I knew what time his flight was and that was the only
thing. So, yeah, like I'm going to be very up front >> Really
is immortal. He's really not going anywhere. He will never die.
He cannot be contained by the law.
No matter what he does, the law the legal system
the legal system can't see Ethan Ralph, okay? He just doesn't
really appear at all to them. Like, oh, what did he do? He punched
a woman in the face? Okay, $0 bail and we're never going to check
in on you again. Bye. Bye. >> this and this is why Ethan
>> Okay, still doesn't make sense, Ethan. Why did they
take your mugshot and then take you to the airport? What What
was What was the pre >> Wait, this guy doesn't understand?
It does make sense that he got drunk at the airport, though.
It actually does. >> The airport. He got drunk at the airport
and he drunk at the >> No, he got arrested before the airport.
He got arrested before the air no, no. >> No, wait. That's
not true. >> in the cops >> arrested at the airport.
>> Her and I had a disagreement. >> The airport police
arrested you? >> No, down the road. The police took me
to the airport where I had further >> Yeah, I I begged
them to give him >> You got arrested before the airport.
>> a courtesy ride to the airport and so then he said further
>> I don't know why it's that complicated. I I dispute
some of the >> No, you got arrested. You got arrested before
the airport. >> saying? Was that okay? >> I'm not
part of his arrest. >> No, she's not. That's what I'm saying.
>> You got it You got your You got a mug I'm You got to
let me talk. Scotty, you You've to let me talk. You got your
You got it. Holy [__] >> Let me talk. Let me
talk. >> You got your mugshot and then they took you to
the airport. So, what did you get arrested for that they took
your
wrong. I went to the airport.
>> Lilly Lilly can't stop talking so she has to walk away.
That's the only way she would stop. Dude, one second. I just
had a
Here we go. Here [clears throat] we go. >> The police.
>> Why Why they don't escort people to to the airport?
>> They do in Wisconsin. They do in Midwest >> So,
what? You can just look at the [__] police department.
>> don't don't interrupt in my life. >> So So So,
you got arrested. So, Scarlett
You say So, you got arrested.
You're saying the police Scarlett, you got to let me talk. So
So So, you're saying >> at the airport. >> So So,
why would they Why would the police drive you to the airport?
>> I don't know. >> Okay, so you're lying. You're
lying. >> No, I'm not lying.
This is why I needed to talk and not him because they talked
to me when they detained him and then I said no, this dude is
fine and then you don't got to worry about this. I said he has
a flight in the morning. He's got to get home to Mexico to feed
his cats and they said, "Okay, we're giving him a courtesy ride
to the airport." I said, "Thank you." I said, "I'm not pressing
charges. I just want him to He has a flight in the morning. He
needs to make >> Bro, those cats going to die. Those cats
are going to die, man. He's not leaving. >> flight. So,
the best >> Does he even have the money? Does he even have
money? Apparently he's got cats in Mexico, okay?
The cats in Mexico He's got cats in
If he doesn't get back, they are going to starve to death. >> police
at that time with the current state was that he goes to the airport
to make his flight. >> Okay, but why was he detained before
the >> He was detained once after the airport. >> down
the street after imbibing a lot of >> And your And your
was held. >> That's all the problems. >> I already
know more than you, honey. Do you want to get up and do you want
me talk for a second alone? >> What do you know more than
>> Please, this would be very nice.
Cuz I was the one that uh >> Bro, am I the only one getting
the vibes from like Once Upon a Time in Hollywood?
That he's like the old man and she's like, "Oh, you need to go
get out of here." Like all all the young women around the old
guy, you know? I just got I just got that vibe. You need to go
over there and just let me talk, okay? >> to call the cops
first and um it wasn't cuz of a vibe. >> He's not going
to live that one down, by the way, with his chat with his
She just She just chased him off the She was like, "Hey, Ralph,
get the [__] out of here. I'm going to talk. I'm
going to talk." >> situation. It wasn't a domestic It wasn't
a mat need. Um this was more like I did not want him to leave
the hotel room because I was >> Does he have a large chat?
He's got a lot of A logs and a lot of haters and I think that
results in the chat being large. I don't know if it's like everybody's
watching for good reasons >> concerned about his present
state of mind and um you know, he's >> But why Why Why
Why did he have to go for a walk? >> I tried to keep him
in the room. >> No, but why did he say Why did he say he
needed to go for a walk? Were you guys about to bust it up? >> What
are you talking about? No, nothing was going >> I'm right
here. She said she wanted to >> No. Talk what? Solo?
I'm still here. >> No, like he's totally fine right now.
I just asked >> I can talk solo, too, like >> I know,
but I just asked to talk alone right now.
>> No, it's nothing wrong with Ethan. I want to make this
very clear. I think that there's a lot of grifters out
There's a lot of snipers. There's a lot of mercers. >> Oh,
boy. Oh, boy.
two lives Dude, this is rough. >> Dr. to listen to.
>> Who's Who's Dr. Teal? >> All these people that
are like terrible people that just snipe and grift off of others
lives. >> Who's Dr. Teal? Exactly. >> Exactly right.
>> That's what I told her. Scarlet, Scarlet, you're living
your life You're living your life on Twitter. You're living your
life on Twitter. So, people are going to snipe you. >> on
my life on Twitter. >> You're not? You You tweeted like
20 times today. >> Now my life becomes Twitter, and so
it's like fine. That's fine. >> You tweeted 20 times today.
>> Yeah, because I retweet things that actually give me
a little bit of hope. Maybe some of them >> No, you you
you tweeted you >> If I retweet something, it's not political.
It's usually cartoon or art related. So, you know, Kevin, like
you're going to retweet things that you like to retweet. And
once in a while you retweet >> said you were texting. You
retweeted >> Yeah, I did. Yeah, you know why? Be- Because
my dad, my father, um he cared about me. >> Uh that's wild
That's a wild thing to say, love. >> Three of my friends
today. >> I'm telling you if you [__] with
me, yeah, that's how it goes. >> You threatened three of
my friends today. I want to put this on record. >> Just
leave. >> One of my friends won't even talk to me more
cuz you threatened her. >> Who cares? I didn't threaten
her. >> You threatened my friend. >> After she blackballed
us, yeah, I did.
Who cares?
Chloe Oughts. And I don't her daughter. >> Keep tweeting
that out if everything's going fine. And why you mad that people
are are curious about it when he's he has a mugshot.
Kiwi Farms is covering it. Again, that's what Kiwi Farms does.
They do it with a Nick Riccardo. They do it with any of these
people get going to jail, [laughter] and people >> Nick
Riccardo. >> like doing curious stuff, and then pretending
that it didn't happen.
Go ahead. >> Yeah, first of all, Kiwi Farms, I have no
idea what that is. >> Okay, it doesn't matter if you know
what it is. Why did you >> He mentioned it already in this.
>> Tweeted out What did you tweet out that your dad said
get away from this guy? >> Well, my dad, somebody had probably
related to one of these uh stalkers that cuz my name was already
doxed, my address, and my family, and my everything was doxed
already. So, how could Ethan dox all that stuff after? And what
is the point? >> Why was your dad worried about Why would
your dad warn you about Ethan Ralph? >> My dad did not
>> Why did you tweet that out? Why did you tweet that out?
>> My dad did not know who Ethan Ralph Can we My dad did
not know who Ethan Ralph >> Dude, Ethan laughing in the
background. She just got so annoyed at him right there. Hold
on. >> you about Ethan Ralph. >> Look at her Look
at her give him the look that she does when he laughs in the
>> My dad did not >> you tweet that out? Why did
you tweet that out? >> My dad did not know who Ethan Ralph
Can we My dad did not know
>> who Ethan Ralph was or is. And why does it matter? Because
my dad did not know about a lot of things. He didn't know who
Matt Meade is. My dad never talked to Matt
Meade. and my dad on a phone and we'll see how my dad treats
him.
Cuz Matt Meade is the one that belonged in jail. And I did not
send Ethan Ralph to jail. You know, this was uh getting drunk
at the airport, getting a little Flurry mixer, and uh you know,
saying some words out loud. >> Flurry mixer? You're talking
about Dairy Queen now? >> Like you McFlurry, you put a
little Snickers and Reese's bar in there at that ice cream and
custard, and then you get some little Flurry in there. And >> What
the [__] is happening?
>> You know, some things get a little bit >> Okay, this
is from your dad. I was told that you're with a really bad person
in Chicago, someone that police are after. They're coming for
him. You should leave him as soon as you can without him knowing.
He's a felon. He's wanted for some horrific crimes. Why would
you be with someone like that? I'm coming down here. I know where
you are. I was told someone sent the police after him. Someone
told me something that scared me. I just want to know if you're
safe. I love you. This is from your dad, and you tweeted you
>> Dude, that's that's [__] up. That's That's
actually [__] up. >> Tweeted it out. YOU TWEETED
>> DAD SAID AFTERWARDS?
OKAY. >> He said "Haha." >> afterwards.
So, I said
he said uh
He started talking to me about taxes.
My dad is like And then he says uh I said uh >> What the
[__] is this? Is she yapping about? The [__]
is she yapping about? >> Just read it. As you said, he
said. So, why was your dad worried about this man you're with,
and you're still with him?
>> Somebody, I don't know exactly who, and I don't know
how I found out. >> You tweeted it out. Why did you tweet
it >> does not do social media. My dad lives in the middle
of nowhere with >> You did. You tweeted it out. >> tweeted
it out, but that's not how my dad found out. MY DAD DOES NOT
HAVE TWITTER. My dad does not know X. My dad All he does >> You
do, and you tweeted it out. >> Yeah, I tweeted it out.
Yeah, but I did not tell my dad. Can you shush? My dad said My
dad told like texted me the night before, but I did not have
have chance to look at my He said was >> it out. You said
"This is a dad who loves their daughter." >> Yeah, my dad
loves me, and I love my
>> This is a dad who loves their daughter. >> Yeah,
my dad loves me, and I love my
>> Bro, I feel like
I don't know. I don't know. I Dude,
it's like robots yelling at each other.
People are starting to feel increasingly less human. Yeah, to
me. And I don't mean that in a dehumanizing way, like I don't
think they're worthy of
I mean that in like a
I I don't know if it's like the internet making people performative
who can't act, but like they're trying to do what they're supposed
to do, and not what they actually feel they're like not anything
from their soul. They're just sort of like following a script
that they've intuited from being on social media.
And I it just all feels like fake. I I
it's just weird. It's >> But my dad did not like he did
he did not know about my situation right now. >> He does
too. He's He's tell He's talking specifically who you're with
right now. >> No, I he doesn't know is because I don't
tell him that she and he doesn't do social media. He's a real
boomer. He's actually a boomer. He's born >> It doesn't
matter if he knows social media. He knows criminal He knows criminal
behavior.
>> No, well, my dad doesn't know anything about anything.
>> He knew about Ethan Ralph. He knew about Ethan Ralph
that he's a he's a well-known well-known felon. >> Okay,
this isn't the same thing. I I got to mute myself. >> even
come back to the country.
He was not allowed in this country for whatever the he did. Now
she's like talking to her lawyer.
You're muted. You're muted. >> I'm in Milwaukee right now.
What do you mean I'm not allowed in the country? That's stupid
as >> I will let you sit down. >> Okay, just shut
>> Why why is Scarlet's dad worried about
>> This chair is >> Are you going to blame me for
her phone now? That's absurd. Like what? >> Dude, she almost
went down the way Ralph went down. Dude, she
Do you think she'd move her feet when she hit the ground? Or
do you think she just lay there on her back with her feet sticking
upwards like Ralph did? >> He's trying to prevent another
man meat from happening, you know. >> I'm in Milwaukee.
>> And he's >> What are you talking about I'm not
allowed in the >> That's barely America. >> allowed
in the country. >> I'm in the USA. I'm in the USA right
now. What do you mean? I just got arrested in the USA Milwaukee
Airport, >> Uh my my my source my sources are saying Ethan
Ralph has taken down his last two
>> I [laughter] I wish that was true, but no, I haven't.
>> I'm not an in-law. I don't have Neither are not related
to my in-laws. He did tell me in my second third family child
we had a son. >> No, you No, these are these are reliable
sources. These are reliable sources.
>> It's the WAY YOU GOT
WOAH, [__]
IT'S THE WAY YOU GOT
>> IT'S THE WAY HIS FEET LIKE PERFECTLY stick up is always
so funny to me, dude.
Every time they just stay And by the way, it takes like another
5 or 10 seconds for him to move his feet after this, I feel like.
They just stay stuck in the air like this. It's so goofy. Say
what you will about Ethan. I never get the fake feeling from
Ethan that I get from other people. At least he's a real human
being, okay, with real >> nothing illegal. >> These
are reliable sources saying Ethan Ralph lies and knows especially
when it comes to father-in-laws.
>> And my father
and my aunt Sharon is the one who works at the my dad to reach
out to >> Oh, Chad has an aunt Sharon, too. >> Her
nephew has is going to prison for a crime that is he was not
actually committed. He was catfished for by >> Nobody cares
nobody Anybody getting catfished. Everybody's Everyone wants
to know about Why are you and Ethan Ralph lying so much? That's
what they want to >> What's he lying about? He sent my
cousin to prison. So, that's why my father >> It's a hell
of a drug, Kevin. You ever heard that line? Who wrote that?
>> I'm not on Neither are you. >> It's a Chappelle
Show joke.
Yeah, sure. It's a hell of a drug.
It's a Chappelle Show. I'm rich, [__] >> What
if Chappelle Show?
>> Uh yeah, you Dude, what is happening? Sometimes I worry
that like I'd have a hard time streaming for some period of time.
But bro, then I look at the other people streaming and I'm just
like, "No, I got this. I got this." My uh My analysis is usually
pretty on point. I can sometimes be funny. Not often funny, but
I can sometimes be funny. I think I'm fine. I think I actually
got this. It's probably going to be fine. >> You said cuz
it's >> Brendan's show. >> I know. The Chappelle
Show. >> This is Kevin BRENNAN'S MISERY LOVES >> HE
knows what show >> podcast show. >> Kevin Brennan,
Brennan Bridges of Compound Media show. >> Yeah, I don't
>> Kevin Brennan, a professional comedian.
>> Kevin Brennan's a father.
think he has kids, I think. I'm not >> Does he does? >> He
does. He does. >> He's got a couple of kids, yeah. >> Yeah,
okay. >> Uh I if he gave me a >> I'm just >> Yeah,
I've heard that people keep saying that he's the that his brother
worked on Chappelle Show. Yeah, I get it. I get it. >> He
gave me a Star Search. >> Kevin Brennan, you said you can
have Steel Toe as your friend. I can have Kevin Brennan as my
friend. >> He's attacking me. I'm just trying to correct
her. >> No, he's not. Hey, but Steel Toe, you know what
Steel Toe's called me a blind what? You know what I call STEEL
TOE? SOFT TOE MOTHER
I will tell him Okay, hey Steel Toe, sit on your knees and cut
cut you corner chair cut
Aaron can't escape the accusations anywhere. He's not even involved.
He's getting called a on this show, too. >> Uh are you
not on any drugs right now? You haven't been drinking? >> I
I'm getting very passionate because I
>> Who is Steel Toe? It's Aaron I can't remember his last
name now. It was the guy who was really close friends with
who did a wife swap with Rakita and then Rakita ended up both
of them and his wife left him. Okay, that's the guy. Aaron Oh,
why can't I get the last name? It's like at the tip of my tongue.
I can't remember it. Aaron
but Steel Toe Morning Show is his show.
And him and Rakita were hanging out, like I said, and did a wife
swap and it turned into a giveaway, I guess. >> I'm not
the person that is going to
>> put anyone under the bus. So, I don't >> Okay,
how about this, Scarlet? How about How about this, Scarlet? >> But
didn't I Didn't he kind of get his manhood back a little bit
because didn't Rakita describe the like Aaron Imholt him? Am
I making that I There's no way I'm making that up, right?
Didn't Rakita basically imply that Aaron Imholt him? So like
technically is that a Is that a 50/50 trade? Is that like an
even trade on manhood right there?